uh prague who uh had a tough day today
but do you think that this is one of
those days where you come away with more
learning
um i think
my playing the first and second game was
um
was good
but then in
in less time i i started to play bad
moves
okay in third game i just
didn't get the position
and then i tried this rook h4 but okay
it was nothing
um
but i think it's a great experience for
me and i always enjoy
um playing top players and of course
definitely magnus playing magnus is
always a fun thing but does it offer you
more motivation for the future to to
take chess even to a further level
um
yeah um
next time i would definitely like to
put better resistance against magnus i
think that's a great motivation
to work even harder i think um
yeah um i just would like to play
remaining games better
did you feel that magnus played at its
best today
um
[Music]
i don't think so um
but because i got a lot of chances in
the first and second game
so i don't think he played this um
at best but
still he's he plays very good
good luck to you tomorrow prague yeah
thank you